he said he's feeling tinges of of like
game time I think there's a chance he
goes tomorrow they'll remote cameras
because we want to stay out of Alex's
line-of-sight he's doing it
okay everybody knows what to do if
something goes wrong Josh just to
confirm who should make you fall the
easiest thing would just be 911 dot we
will get kicked into gear and tell them
what you know climber yeah all right
no mistakes tomorrow
I'm worried that tomorrow's gonna be it
like you know like Alex's existence will
be over I was like oh I have to be
prepared for that outcome and I have to
realize that that is a real possibility
[Applause]
you're gonna stand up for my goodbyes
oh is it time yeah
[Music]
I mean I didn't ask her to leave I mean
I would never ask her to leave but you
know I think she kind of understands
that it's probably easier for me if
she's gone the whole like saying goodbye
thing I'm like I'll probably see her in
like five days it's not like goodbye
it's just goodbye for a few days
you know I mean there's just that like
weird thought of like don't freakin let
that be our last hug or whatever you
know like I shouldn't be having that
thought
like what if something happens like what
if I don't see it you're like why do you
want to do this like it's it's totally
crazy
goal
[Music]